the 2010 saw Hollywood blockbusters
making Bank like never before it was a
decade of Disney dominance and franchise
fever where pretty much every top earner
was a sequel to a previous movie usually
one involving a lightsaber or an
infinity stone but exactly which movies
won out in each year
Disney kicked off its best ever decade
with the third film in the franchise
that changed animation forever Toy Story
3
the original Toy Story launched the
series made Pixar a household name and
became the biggest grosser of 1995 Toy
Story 2 came out four years later and
earned even more than its predecessor
with results like that a third film
seemed like a no-brainer but it would be
a whole 11 years before Pixar returned
to the series while Pixar made billions
in the interim animation fans were still
desperate to see the conclusion to the
original Pixar series and they got their
wish when toy story 3 opened in 2010 it
was worth the wait - as a film earned an
amazing 98% tomato meter score with a
stellar box-office performance to match
its own 415 million dollars domestically
and more than 1 billion dollars
worldwide making Toy Story 3 the
highest-grossing movie released in 2010
here's a catch for you though it wasn't
actually the movie to earn the most
money in 2010 that Sarna went to avatar
which was released in late 2009 but made
466 million dollars domestically in the
year that followed
of course what Toy Story 3 seemed like
the perfect conclusion to the trilogy
everyone knows by now that you just
can't keep a billion-dollar franchise
down Toy Story fours released in 2019 a
manís our performance predecessor with a
worldwide take of 1.7 billion dollars
and beyond
how he Potter was big business at the
box office the franchise consisting of
the seven Harry Potter films and the two
fantastic beasts prequels has totaled
more than two point seven billion
dollars domestically and nearly nine
point two billion dollars worldwide the
high point and the franchise came at the
very end of its first run with twenty
eleven Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows part-2 Deathly Hallows part-2
was pitched as the epic conclusion to
the eighth film saga that had begun
ten years before with Harry Potter and
the Sorcerer's Stone a movie that had
itself been the highest-grossing movie
of 2001 surprisingly the Harry Potter
series wouldn't hit them was like that
again until his final installments
anticipation for the movie was at a
fever pitch right before release so much
so that Deathly Hallows Part 2 sets a
venn opening-weekend record of 169
million dollars on its way to a total
domestic gross of 381 million dollars
and a worldwide gross of 1.3 billion
dollars all in all it was a good year to
be a boy wizard but his reign at the top
would be short-lived it's hard to
believe now but Marvel's grand
experiment of a shed cinematic universe
once had an insert in the future at the
box office I am man exceeded all
expectations when it opened in 2008
taking a b-level comic-book character
and giving him a movie that earns 318
million dollars domestically and five
hundred and eighty five million dollars
worldwide is it better to be feared or
respected nicely is it too much to ask
for both
however the ensuing MCU films weren't
quite as successful The Incredible Hulk
bombed in 2008 of 134 million dollars
domestic and two hundred and sixty three
million dollars worldwide only barely
managing to make back its own budget
while Thor and Captain America the First
Avenger fared better in 2011 none of
these films really screams the biggest
blockbuster franchise ever if anything
the Avengers felt like it might be
little more than Iron Man and friends
but movie history had other plans
The Avengers set up an opening-weekend
record of 207 million dollars becoming
the first movie to open with more than
200 million dollars and soon ended up
with six hundred and twenty three
million dollars temesta can 1.5 billion
dollar worldwide total but as amazing as
these numbers were the Avengers greatest
achievement was giving the Marvel
Cinematic Universe a kick in the tights
it needed to to become a twenty two
point five billion dollar power
twenty two point five billion in
counting matters this he may have
dominated the decade but in 2013 the
biggest hit at the domestic box office
came from a much smaller film studio
Lionsgate the studio had previously
scored a major coup when it won the
rights to Suzanne Collins widely popular
novel series The Hunger Games the first
film launched a franchise in a big way
earning one hundred and fifty two
million dollars in its opening weekend
on its way to 400 million dollars
domestic and six hundred and ninety four
million dollars worldwide its sequel The
Hunger Games Catching Fire opened with
one hundred and fifty eight million
dollars and earned four hundred and
twenty four million dollars in the
United States and eight hundred and
sixty five million dollars worldwide
becoming the highest grossing film of
2013 but only domestically beyond the US
the big winner of 2013 was a surprise
disney animated smash hit frozen frozen
opened on a1 theatre limited release in
late 2013 with two hundred and forty
three thousand dollars but then leg dis
way to four hundred million dollars
domestic and an incredible one point two
seven billion dollars worldwide well
nobody should ever count out disney at
the box office
frozen becoming 2013's biggest hit
worldwide was still surprising given it
wasn't a sequel reboot or remake and
wasn't based on a popular pre-existing
property either from a wider perspective
twenty thirteen proof that the global
box office was more important than ever
as the biggest semester kids didn't
actually become the biggest hit
worldwide a trend that would continue in
the years ahead
for decades audiences movie-going diets
have been fattened by sequels reboots
and remakes given this movie's going
landscape American sniper was a genuine
milestone in 2014 it was the first
original property since 2011 to top the
domestic box-office and the only movie
this century to do so that wasn't a
big-budget CG infused blockbuster this
achievement is all the more impressive
considering the movie was also given in
our rating that said American sniper
status as 2014's biggest movie is a bit
of a misnomer since it actually made
most of its money in 2015 the movie
first opened at limited release in
December 2014 making a little more than
six hundred and thirty three thousand
dollars in just four theaters it opened
wide in January 2015 with an incredible
92 million dollars and continued to leg
it out to a 350 million dollar domestic
haul and
American sniper was a number one hit
domestically its total worldwide take
didn't even secure it a spot in the top
10 the year's biggest worldwide hit was
and surprisingly a franchise picture
transformers age of extinction the
fourth film in the Transformers series
made us soso 245 million dollars to
messily but it was big business overseas
with a total worldwide take of just a
little more than 1.1 billion dollars
American sniper may have been a historic
achievement stateside but worldwide
Chris Kyle couldn't top the buds Disney
purchased Lucasfilm in 2012 for four
billion dollars and they didn't do it
just to release a Star Wars Holiday
Special on blu-ray
no the mouse house was on a serious
mission to resurrect the beloved
franchise from a galaxy far far away
inevitably Star Wars The Force awakens
became one of the most anticipated films
of the century fans had waited decades
to see what happened to Han Luke Leia
and the gang after the Empire had fallen
in 1983's Return of the Jedi this would
be the first Star Wars film in ten years
- as well as the first that wasn't a
prequel in 32 years it'd also be the
first ever that wasn't led by series
creator George Lucas while the original
Star Wars helped invent the summer movie
season this would be the first film in
the franchise to open during the holiday
season this turns out to be a brilliant
move
the force awakens open like a summer
blockbuster with a then-record 247
million dollars but had the legs of a
holiday release by the end of its run
the movie had earned 936 million dollars
stateside to become not only the number
one domestic release of 2015 but the
then biggest semester hit of all-time
the force was strong overseas - as a
film earned just over two billion
dollars globally making it the biggest
hit worldwide of 2015 almost inevitably
Disney won 2016 - with the biggest
box-office hit both domestically and
worldwide though those were different
movies Captain America Civil War kicked
things off opening in the spring of 2016
and pitting cap against Iron Man in a
franchise shaking fight to the death
adding Robert Downey jr. stonyside to
the movie proved to be a big boon to the
film's box office as civil war opened to
179 million dollars nearly twice as much
as its predecessor the Winter Soldier
the movie managed the massive four
hundred and eight million dollars
domestic gross and more importantly made
a grand total of 1.15 billion dollars
quickly becoming the big
global box office hit of 2016 after Star
Wars The Force awakens historic run join
the 2015 holiday season
Disney wisely chose to release rogue one
a Star Wars story in December 2016 rogue
1 was the first Star Wars movie that
wasn't part of the main Skywalker saga
but moviegoers were nonetheless ravenous
for more the movie opened to 155 million
dollars on its way to a five hundred and
thirty two million dollars domestic take
and just over 1 billion dollars
worldwide making it the biggest semester
hit of 2016 and number two worldwide the
battle for box office supremacy was no
longer a fight between rival Studios it
was a fight between rival Disney
properties I got a bad feeling about
this before the year even began the
biggest box-office hit of 2017 was
practically a given saw Wars the last
Jedi it was just a matter of how much
money Rian Johnson's follow-up to the
force awakens would make that said 2017
featured strong performances from
several other films Disney's live-action
Beauty and the Beast remake opened in
the spring earning 504 million dollars
domestically and one point two six
billion dollars worldwide the fate of
the Furious opened in the summer earning
a respectable 226 million dollars
domestically but making an insane 1.2
billion dollars worldwide becoming the
year's biggest international hits by a
pretty sizable margin
you can't stop destiny though and Star
Wars was destined to dominate the last
Jedi Open joined the 2017 holiday season
with 220 million dollars less than his
predecessor but that wasn't too
surprising given it wasn't preceded by
decades of pent up demand it's possible
that a divided response from moviegoers
and the stronger-than-expected
performance from Jumanji welcome to the
jungle didn't exactly help either but
the film made six hundred and twenty
million dollars to Mexicali and 1.3
billion dollars worldwide making it
easily the biggest hit of the year and
that's not so bad is it the only Star
Wars movie released in 2018 somehow
managed to tank at the box office so it
soon became pretty obvious that a Marvel
movie would take the year sub spot
however the Marvel movie that won the
day domestically was a bit of a surprise
black panther opened in February a
season not typically known for
blockbuster releases and wrote a wave of
awesome reviews and positive sentiment
to
a mammoth 202 million dollars on its
opening weekend black panther wasn't a
one weekend wonder either as it
continued to leg it out earning a
historic 700 million dollars
domestically and 1.3 billion dollars
worldwide black panther was a biggest
domestic hit of 2018 and is one of only
a handful of movies ever to earn more
than 700 million dollars at the domestic
box office
buh-bah the movie was a historic
surprise the biggest worldwide earner
was a given Avengers infinity war was
the beginning of the sort of end for the
most successful franchise of all time
bringing together a range of characters
from across the entire MCU with
anticipation at a fever pitch infinity
war set there then opening weekend
record with 257 million dollars the
movie couldn't quite match Black
Panthers runaway success at the domestic
box office there it still earned a
mammoth six hundred and seventy eight
million dollars stateside and with a
global take of just over two billion
dollars it was the biggest hit of the
year worldwide by far
after infinity Wars shocking cliffhanger
ending Disney made a shrewd decision
with the marketing for the movie's
follow-up fans didn't even know the
film's title until a few months before
his release and the trailers revealed
practically nothing about the story only
that the stories remaining heroes would
do whatever it takes to stop vanos this
mysterious marketing campaign paid off
in spades while it was set in stone that
Avengers endgame would break records not
even the most optimistic observers could
predict that the movie would have
literally the opening weekend record set
by his predecessor earning three hundred
and fifty seven million dollars
domestically and more than 1.2 billion
dollars worldwide a mid-summer expansion
propelled and games funnel grows to
eight hundred and fifty eight million
dollars to Messick lee and an incredible
2.7 nine billion dollars worldwide it's
combined totes what makes it not only
the biggest hit of 2019 stateside and
the worldwide but the highest grossing
film of all time to check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]